quels sont vos coups de coeur qu'elle
fine peut-on regarder pendant cette
période de confinement c'est edward aux
mains d'argent
un film de tim burton qui est sorti en
1991 peut-être l'avez-vous vu vous même
ou effectivement bon vous avez aimé je
suppose
oui c'est très magique comme film oui
c'est magique alors c'est un conte de
fées en fait effectivement avec un
personnage à la fois inquiétant et
attachant alors edouard vous souvenez
c'est une créature humaine qui a été
mise au point par un inventeur qui lui a
donné un coeur qui lui a donné un
cerveau intelligent mais qui n'a pas eu
le temps de finir tout à fait son
physique et notamment ses mains qui se
terminent actuellement par des des lames
coupante et pointue et l'inventeur va
mourir et laisse cette créature
et rés alors tout le récit c'est
évidemment sortir d'un isolement dans
une propriété un peu magique et
inquiétante assez gothique et il va
devoir en fait affronter le monde et
peut-être trouvé la mort alors les
atouts de ce film qui est célèbre parce
que il ya eu 91 % de taux de
satisfaction dans toutes les critiques
ce qui est absolument énorme et même le
public a vraiment plébiscité ce film
alors d'abord il est à la croisée des
gens c'est à la fois un conte c'est
fantastique
mais c'est un peu comme eddy aussi et
puis c'est finalement un drame
romantique alors le film a comme atout
aussi de démarrer un trio gagnant
c'est tim burton d'abord le réalisateur
qui va en fait faire alliance avec son
acteur qui va devenir son acteur fétiche
johnny depp
alors on le retrouvera plus tard dans ed
wood dans ce qui est pire l'eau ou dans
sweeney todd
johnny depp était à l'époque un acteur
peu connu il avait surtout été un
policier dans la série 21 jump street
et là il va éclore il va trouver son
réalisateur et le récepteur va également
trouver non seulement cet acteur majeur
mais également un compositeur absolument
géniale qui est danny elfman et qui va
composer une musique extraordinaire
en tout cas dany elfman considère que
cette oeuvre edward aux mains d'argent
et la musique la plus personnelle tout
comme d'ailleurs les acteurs qui
trouvent que ce film est tout à fait à
son image
petite dernière anecdote on voit
vinh-san price qui est un acteur qui a
beaucoup joué
le compte de granulats mais également
frankenstein qui fait sa dernière
apparition dans ce film c'est lui
l'inventeur de la créature